according to the police i'm a hardened
criminal so you're an aspiring mobster
in the 1950s that came from humble
beginnings you live in a tiny beat-up
home with your parents at the bottom of
society with no power or status
and yet you see all these mob bosses
flashing their tail with suits jewelry
cars women
and you yearn for that the money the
power the status to command respect when
you walk into a room
but in order to be that mob boss you
have to ascend the ranks of the mafia
and what is the best way to ascend the
ranks of the mafia finding a way to make
easy money from something that is always
in demand also known as being a
racketeer and earner
sure you could go for extorting
construction companies substance
smuggling or even laundering money
through casinos but the problem is these
rackets are well known and the
competition is fierce if you're not
taken out by a rival mob there's
probably going to be a cop watching your
every move you need something simpler
something that is easy to control less
obvious so it draws less attention while
still making you rich
then one day you strike gold trash
yes you heard that right becoming a
trashman collecting garbage waste
management whatever you want to call it
i'm in a waste management business the
stuff people leave in their driveways
for trucks to collect every few days now
i know what you're thinking trash that's
so unsexy why would the mafia get
involved in that exactly that reaction
you just had is the exact same reaction
the feds are going to have it's low key
unexpected and easier to stay under the
radar garbage business yeah i know
compared to running a casino or
smuggling taking bags of trash from
point a to point b is insanely simple
you don't even need a lot of capital to
get started all you need is a truck and
a couple of street guys who are just
bubbling to have an opportunity to make
money and move up the ranks and there
will always be a demand for the service
in the 1960s the average american
produced just over 2.5 pounds of trash a
day today the trash industry in the us
is worth more than 63 billion dollars
not a bad number for something no one
pays attention to plus the business is
legal not only can you make money
without the cops breathing down your
neck the cops are finally leaving
garbage alone but such a boring
inconspicuous business is perfect for
laundering all your mafia's dirty money
the only problem is the government was
in charge of collecting trash for most
of the 20th century so if you're
planning on getting in the waste
management business you need to wait for
the right opportunity to come and that
opportunity came in 1957 and resulted in
the rise of a new breed of mobsters the
garbage racketeers
[Music]
hello hello hello
we bet you hate
so please let us take your trash review
[Music]
wait wait stop i i have to stop you damn
it dennis i knew this was no the plan
was good charlie you were sharp it was
he he were a little short
guys guys the song was fine
did you say you would take my trash
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the mob controls an industry that's a
necessity to every single one of us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before a long day of working your
rackets every good mobster needs a
quality cup of coffee but making fresh
delicious coffee is time consuming and
tedious and the alternative
unsophisticated instant coffee is for
plums if only there was a way to make
coffee that is just as fast as instant
coffee while being just as high quality
as freshly brewed hipster coffee for all
you caffeine addicts enter commentary
today's video sponsor now i am an
incredibly lazy person i hate cooking
and i hate making coffee because it
takes way too much time for a drink that
i just finished in like one minute that
is where commentary comes in commentary
is unlike any other coffee there's
nothing quite like it on the market
right now how it works is that
commentary partners with the best
regional roasters and then comment your
grinds and bruise the coffee to
perfection and then they immediately
flash freeze it and because they flash
squeeze it it locks in the flavor and
freshness unlike any other coffee
solution and then it ships right to your
door in these nice little boxes and
inside each box are these little
capsules that you keep in the freezer
and then when you're ready if you like
hot coffee all you gotta do is take one
of these open them up squeeze it into a
glass add hot water and that's literally
it but i like latte so here's what we're
gonna do ice you leave one of these out
in the fridge so it melts add milk
open it up and pour it in
and now you have an amazing glass of
latte in like three seconds
and that is how you have hipster level
coffee in about 10 seconds without going
to the coffee store without wasting a
bunch of money there without wasting
money on really bad coffee like instant
coffee and for a limited time commentary
is giving you guys a special offer just
for the fans of this channel you can get
20 off your first order right now with
the link below that's 10 capsules of
coffee for free with always free
shipping that's 20 off with the link
below
by the start of the 20th century cities
like new york suddenly had a lot more
people living there which led to a lot
more garbage being produced so to deal
with the trash the city basically just
threw most of it into the ocean which
obviously made coastal cities in new
jersey pretty annoyed so in 1935 the
coastal cities of new jersey filed a
lawsuit against new york that forced
them to end their ocean dumping entirely
now new york was left with thousands of
tons of trash with nowhere to put it
they plan to build some new incinerators
but then the great depression hit
followed by world war ii and all these
ambitious ideas had to be scaled down
all the while the garbage just kept
piling up that was until 1957 when new
york's municipal authorities decided
that they were tired of being
responsible for the mountain of trash
the city's residents were creating so
they stopped collecting commercial waste
entirely if businesses want to get rid
of their trash they would have to hire
private companies to do it that way the
blame would go on these private
companies instead of land for the trash
problem in other words the government of
new york privatized the collecting of
trash from companies and this was the
opportunity you've been waiting for see
at first this new arrangement worked
really well and a lot of garbage was
being transported to landfills and
incinerators outside of new york city
where the opportunity comes in is that
these trash businesses are ran by
average everyday people these people
aren't used to being threatened with
violence they're businessmen laborers so
the moment you threaten them with
violence the moment you send a couple of
thugs their way to tell them to raise
their prices or suffer the consequences
for example they will obey what are they
gonna do call the police the same police
that is probably under your payroll yeah
sure so you set up a garbage collection
service and start wiping out your
competition you threaten competitors to
inflate their prices up 10 times the
market rate
if anyone lowers their prices you
convince them to raise their prices back
up at the point of a gun you tamper with
weight scales to make it look like
you're transporting more trash and then
pocketing the difference and if your
loyal customers ever try to use a
different company to remove their trash
you have a friendly conversation with
them thus making sure they always go
with you so now that you have a pretty
good small scale operation going on it's
time to take it a step further and scale
it up
[Music]
the next step is to infiltrate the labor
unions for garbagemen and take them over
once you do that you are now the boss of
a bunch of garbage collectors for a
given area that all use these strong arm
tactics against competitors and
customers as the mafia gained more and
more of a foothold in the industry they
split most cities up into territories
just like they did to sell substances
and to extort people each territory had
its own number of stops mafia slang for
customers that needed their trash picked
up and in an actual free markets these
customers would choose the cheaper
garbage collector and go with them this
competition for customers would drive
down the cost of garbage collection but
as you know competition is a sin since
you control the garbage union you get to
dictate how much all the garbage
collectors for a given area are allowed
to charge and for any garbage men in the
area that aren't a part of your racket i
mean union you can always convince them
at the point of a gun to price their
services higher than yours so customers
have no choice but to go to you
that way all the good jobs for huge
corporations that produce a ton of trash
go to you
they're using threats and violence to
gain and hold a monopoly on commercial
garbage collection and the co-op city
section of the bronx and to top it all
off even if these customers didn't want
to use your mafia affiliated services
and they wanted to pay extra to use your
competitors they had no choice there is
no switching your garbage company in the
bronx erl kaufman comes to me and says i
want to dispose of your garbage
if joe smith another garbage company
operator comes to me and says i want to
dispose of your garbage for
two dollars less a drum or a yard than
harold kaufman
why can't i give my business to joe
smith because you won't get your truck
out of there you'll either get your
truck blown up or you'll get trouble
under property rights you just don't do
that once you put your trash in a trash
can outside in a dumpster on the
sidewalk in the case of new york you've
legally abandoned that property either
entirely or at least directly to the
trash hauling service
since the mafia controlled all the stops
they're the only possible ones that the
trash could legally be transferred to
they'd legally own the right to collect
all that trash as soon as the waste was
placed in the bins near the road it
belonged to the mob
and the mob have my have the property
rights over you don't know you don't
know it's your company it's your garbage
but you don't own it i own it i have the
property rights i harold kaufman have
the property right because if i don't
i'll go to vinnie mar he'll kill you
that's the way organized crime has been
in there from the word go and again if
anyone stepped out of line if any new
competitors popped up trying to poach
your customers they would soon regret it
threats violence beating people up with
baseball bats fire bombing garbage
trucks and even the occasional hits were
all just another day in the life of a
garbage racketeer mr mayhem came with
his trucks took the garbage put the
compactors in there he's ready to do the
big job first thing that happened to all
his trucks where sand was put in it
didn't work mr man was stubborn then a
gun was put to mr mayhem's head he was
given a choice either get out or you
won't have to worry about picking up
garbage
[Music]
so now that you've conquered the regular
trash business it's time to expand into
the next vertical chemical waste
disposal
kaufman said it was easy for them to get
temporary state disposal licenses and
then just let the chemical drums pile up
see disposing chemical waste is much
more profitable than regular trash but
only if you do it in the right way this
is because chemical waste can't go into
the same landfills as regular trash you
need to process them as specialized
facilities and landfills that are able
to protect the environment from chemical
spills because of this chemical
companies pay big money to get rid of
their chemical and hazardous waste way
more than they would pay for regular
trash so obviously this is the next
logical step to build your empire and
where the opportunity lies is that
instead of actually taking the expensive
steps to dispose of these chemicals in a
safe manner you simply take all that
dangerous toxic chemical waste mix it in
with your regular trash and dump it
straight into normal landfills after all
you've been dumping garbage in the same
places for years so who would ever
suspect something was wrong and then you
can pocket the giant difference and if
toxic waste made you rich recycling made
you even wealthier just like toxic waste
collecting recyclables costs way more
than normal trash that's because you
have to sort it clean it and send it off
to separate recycling plants but again
you can just sidestep all of that mixing
the recyclables with regular trash and
pocket the difference
they save all those costs of cleaning up
the material they save the time and the
prospect time of going out and securing
markets for the sale of the material on
top of all this legitimate cash flow the
trash business also allows you to loan
their money and to have proof of
employment to make it look like all your
other dirty money came from this
legitimate business
but then it all came tumbling down in
the 90s
by the 1970s the mob was getting
decimated by a new law called the rico
act this allowed the feds to prosecute
mob bosses by tying the crimes of their
underlings to them but the mob's grip on
the garbage business was still strong
that was until the 1990s other
legitimate businessmen started noticing
how much money was in the garbage
industry and won it in as well so the
industry became more and more
corporatized as these corporations grew
bigger and bigger eventually not even a
mobster could go up against these
companies that had millions upon
millions of dollars these corporations
were able to build waste disposal
facilities buy up landfills and compete
on a level that the mob just couldn't
match
the last straw was when a new licensing
agency and the new york city trade waste
commission were formed to regulate the
industry and finally kick out the
mafia's garbage cartel and it worked
none of the mobsters could get licenses
to transport waste that was when the
mafia's garbage cartel came to a
grinding hall in america
but outside the us this racket is still
going strong
[Music]
today the waste disposal business in
naples italy is completely controlled by
one mafia family the kimora they're one
of the oldest and largest organized
crime syndicates in italy even older
than the sicilian mafia and they've been
controlling the trash industry for at
least 25 years just like the american
mafia they dump toxic waste into normal
landfills or on land they buy in the
countryside poisoning a lot of people
and animals in the process
they lease their properties to other
italian waste haulers too which means
even more trash is dumped in naples in
the end there aren't any landfills
available for public waste for the city
of naples itself which means most of it
ends up in the street and highways and
it's not just in italy in other parts of
europe and even taiwan mafia bosses have
taken over the trash business with
devastating consequences for the locals
another men's trash really is another
mafioso's treasure
if this is your first time watching this
channel we make video essays
documentaries just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
stuff in the world of money power war
and crime so if you enjoyed this video
you're definitely gonna enjoy the other
one so click that subscribe button below
it's completely free and you can always
dislike unsubscribe and leave me your
best hate comments below if you want
more day in the life kind of stuff you
can follow me on instagram jaytrend.io
the more you guys watch the video to the
end the better it is for the youtube
algorithm so seriously thank you so much
for being part of the washington club
keep sharpening that mind stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you